from calorie counts to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between lays in the US and in China this
is food Wars
[Music]
in China Lays chips come in 14 that's
right 14 sizes coming in at our smallest
chip bag 12 grams 23 40 there's a 45 but
we couldn't get that 60 65 70 75 grams
1890 104
135 and
220 grams for our largest chip packet in
the US latest come in six sizes there's
only four let me explain down here the
smallest bag is the multi-pack 28 gram
bag the vending machine bag move one up
to a 2.625
ounce or 74.4 grams so specific then in
the middle which I couldn't find is a
2.75 ounce or 78 gram bag in the middle
here the cloud I mean this is the one
you see everyone the 8 ounce or 226 gram
bag in the middle here missing is the
family size too tragic for the American
family they don't get to see the 10.5
ounce or
297.6 gram bag but of course the size
that we always have Old Reliable the
biggest size the party size
368 grams that means the biggest bag in
the U.S is 67.3 larger than the biggest
bag in China it's not the size that
matters Joe it's
no wait no actually it is the size in
the US our flavored bags weigh less than
the original flavored bags take this bag
of barbecued lays it weighs
7.75 ounces compared to the eight ounces
you get with the original bag same price
but less product back in 2014 PepsiCo
claimed quote the reason for the
slightly higher price per ounce for
flavor chips is the added seasoning
interesting so lace can you explain to
me why this bag of lightly salted chips
is 7.75 or 7 3 4 like the flavored bags
and that eight ounces of the regular
salted bags where all this has for
seasoning
is less salt than the original it lays
where's my salt a 28 gram bag in the U.S
supposedly contains 15 chips according
to Lay's website
uh let's see how accurate this is I hate
doing this I really hate doing this we
don't have a 28 gram bag so I'll count
the number of chips in a 40 gram packet
as a comparison it's 1.43 times heavier
which is it just as plentiful
four
ten eleven I'm I'm running out of big
chips now it's all the small ones
like a lot more than 15. closer to like
21. that was very generous of you lays I
see the Finish Line That's roughly 24
and
oh
25 chips in a 40 gram packet okay I'm
already incredibly impressed at the
number of chips they managed to fit into
this bag but they really could have put
more in there and we all know that lays
chip bags are mostly filled with air
anyway it's actually nitrogen gas which
helps preserve the chips and also acts
as a cushion to start them from getting
smashed in transit I mean
okay but what is the air to chip ratio
you ask
it's a rhetorical question let's find
out I'm going to take the smallest
packet that we have the 12 grams so
that's
533.3 milliliters
I feel like I'm on the Food Network okay
now we need to find out the volume of
the chips 15 our ratio
is
0.028 chips to air which makes it 2.8
chips and the rest of it is all Air
incredibly scientifically accurate
experiment yields 575 milliliters in the
bag let's do
five bags and then we'll just get a
bigger number then divide that by five
because we'll have an average smart
great
oh yeah you guys have no idea how
satisfying this is
born in 25 divided by five equals
85. I forgot what it was can someone do
that on screen for us please
and there's the number we've been trying
to get
here are all the lace chips from China
that you won't find in the US and here
are most of the lace chips from the US
you won't find in China all right let's
start with the exclusive flavors for the
classic chip style now these four are
the most common flavors that you'll find
here on the Chinese market beginning
with Italian red meat wow it's nice and
red so we're probably going for
bolognese sauce here
it's not offensive
but you also can't quite place what
exactly they were trying to do next we
have the Mexican chicken tomato
oh that is delicious next we have the
Texas grilled barbecue flavor
it tastes Savory last but not least
cucumber flavor
why just why
just walk I don't know what I'm eating
what is this it's sweet it's refreshing
it has an aftertaste of cucumber I want
to ask why
but I also kind of I'm okay with it it's
it's kind of nice you know I wonder if
these are popular because they're
foreign flavors because we don't know
what Italian red meat or Mexican chicken
tomato is supposed to taste like and
apparently neither do you guys all right
let's move on to our exclusive local
flavors
the spicy crayfish or as you guys in the
US would call them crawfish
yes
that smells legit oh it tastes a little
bit less crayfish than it smells like
crayfish
no no that's good that's good oh it's
got that aftertaste wow that is pretty
authentic roasted cumin lamb skewer
hands down my all-time favorite street
food this is Iconic especially in summer
you'll see people hanging out in the
alleys with their tank top rolled up so
their belly is exposed we call that the
Beijing bikini here and then they'll be
holding a a bunch of these skewers with
meat just ripping them off and slamming
back the beers oh best things about
China are it's street food honestly
no I can see it's there it's not as
meaty as I would like but then look it's
a potato chip all right I think they've
done pretty well what do we have here
seaweed flavor roast garlic oyster I
think they should just rename this
lineup to the street food Edition
[Laughter]
Wasabi flavor
oh
oh if you finish a bag of this block
nose and go on
fried crab
holy crap
wow they've done really well
numb and spicy hot pot
it's spicy
I haven't got the numb yet maybe I need
to eat more the more you eat hot pot the
more the the broth simmers down the
spicier it becomes so at the end your
hot pot is way spicier than at the start
this feels a little bit like that right
now here we have another popular flavor
from the south from Citron this is roast
fish and we've got a special flavor from
a past season truffle
oh
okay maybe I'm just low brow I don't
like the flavor of travel it tastes like
a a wet Forest oh no thank you hold this
up we have a lot so many exclusive
flavors it's quite robust uh I was not
able to get all of them season ones I
could find here in Southern California
first one salt and vinegar
come on China I like salt and vinegar
better than plain potato chips
Sweet Southern heat barbecue
different than a regular barbecue sweet
and barbecue flavor I think I like these
better than regular barbecue chips let's
compare regular us barbecue
Sweet Southern Heat
these are better speaking of barbecue
honey barbecue
that's just okay you know this is not
very honey-ish you want the sweet it's
sweeter than one honey
go figure oh yeah cheddar and sour cream
I mean this thing
no top five over here these are really
good we got lemon flavored these are
lime flavor chips with I don't know who
this person is this is a guy in Ted
lasso I don't know who this is cesando
is that his name it's like a one
I have no idea what
yeah
what lime and potato together look at
that
I hate pickles
but I like Dill
but I should and Siri like this
nope yeah
go away forever do not like Dill
flavored chips they also have flaming
hot dill pickle chips gonna get my hands
in a bag but I did get my hands on a bag
of just the flaming hot chips oh man
it's like really red
flaming hot yeah yep
spicy yes flavorful not so much ones I
think I'm gonna like chili them on not
as spicy way more flavorful oh yeah in
the lime aftertaste my eyes are
fantastic these might be my favorite
if I had to organize these in my
favorites these are my favorite these
are delicious these are all really good
everything to here on is like wood grab
do enjoy
the honey barbecue is not that sweet
finding hot yeah hot but not really
flavorful until dill pickles pickle suck
you can also get the adobe's flavor the
Doritos Cool Ranch Lays
flavor and a cheddar jalapeno which I
really wanted to get couldn't get my
hands down all right on to our regional
Limited
starting with
the spicy chicken with rat and pepper
now this is a very popular dish from
Sichuan Province down in Southwest China
that Aroma is legit
very legit
this is way more numbing than the spicy
and numbing hot pot
and more spicy too the Hot Pot strikes
back this time it's the spicy hot pot
now I don't taste the beef oil in there
I don't get the Savory nah this is my
sesame sauce hot pot
this is
Cantonese flavor ah
for once this is Sam turning roast Goose
flavor
oh oh well done
yes yes
huh Sam tongue represent
marinated chicken feet
stir-fried chicken now this originates
from Shandong province which is over in
Eastern China they're quite fond of
their stews and braises over there meats
and vegetables that have been cooked for
a very long time so hopefully this will
be very flavorful
you can taste the sort of um a roast
meat flavor especially when you cook
with a Chinese Wok there's a bit of
smokiness that is attached to the to the
meat after you've cooked it I feel like
I'm getting that here we're back to the
Chinese flavors again this is um
it's called latitude so it's basically
stir-fried chicken in a mountain of
chilies you know that the whole point of
laity is not to eat tons of chicken but
to find chicken from within the mountain
of Chili's it's a dish that goes
especially well
beer
there we go
we have another Hot Pot this I think is
the most pointless kind of hot pot this
is hot pot for people who can't eat
spicy or numbing hot pot for people like
you out there we have tomato hot pot
I'll go fair enough
it's quite tasty
now for our 2023 spring lineup
beginning with
oh
salt and pepper mantis shrimp
what do we have next oh Beef Wellington
oh my God
oh I I'm speechless
this leaves me very confused
it just tastes like butter and last but
not least we've got the
takoyaki flavored chips these are
Japanese Street Food
oh well
um the smokiness is on point
we have a bunch of chips to our
varieties
in the US starting with another thick
chip variety kettle cooked I don't know
what it means I'm assuming they cook
them in a kettle I don't know how I
don't know how to make regular chips so
many flavors to choose from sea salt and
vinegar sea salt and Cracked Pepper
Mesquite barbecue jalapeno everyone in
the US I want to tell you right now
these chips fantastic these might be my
favorite chips these are so good
hmm
other flavors include original flaming
hot and Maui onion all right now on to
our selection of wavy and wavy Limited
beginning with our roast chicken wing
this feels thicker than the regular chip
very crunchy
I'm starting to get the roast chicken in
there that's decent the rose squid
not that big a fan of roast squid to be
honest but I will try
the roast pork it's tasty but I can't
really get the pork in there I think the
chicken is still better this just says
pure spicy
as if we haven't already eaten enough
spicy chips
and tomato nah nah this can stay
unopened moving on to our wavy limited
these are a collaboration with another
snack brand here in China called Juan
feihong who make spicy peanuts this one
is
hot and sour chicken feet this is the
spicy peanut flavor for with the Huang
FEI Hong brand is best known
tastes like spicy peanuts but in chip
form okay I'm dropped many of you must
be super curious as to what this is this
is Lay's choco Ridge which is a collab
with a brand that's literally called
lickic uh this is their cheesecake
flavored chocolate Rich I've never had
this either a sweet dessert place wow
this is so wrong that it's so ripe wow
wow
very high expectations for this now this
is the choco Ridge chocolate truffle
here you can actually see how it's
literally just a regular lays crisp
covered in chocolate well done um this
is a good collab we have something
similar our wavy style chips uh these
are three of the many options you can
get here in the US of course starting
with original we also have Hickory
Barbecue
this is like they combine funions and
wavy together always weird
let's get those you can also get wavy
reduced fat original wavy Ranch wavy
salt and pepper and wavy lightly salted
now onto our non-potato options of which
we have a lot
these are all yam yams have
subcategories of yam crisps and yam
rolls as well these are the black sesame
and chia seed yam crisp man they sound
healthy don't they so in traditional
Chinese medicine black sesame is thought
to help with hair growth I've been
recommended it a lot
I can taste the nuttiness of the black
sesame
and I feel like my hairline is coming
back any moment now this is also
something that adheres to traditional
Chinese medicine Chinese dates and Goji
berries these are delicious
wow here we have pastoral tomatoes
roast chicken wing on to our yam rolls
these are an upgraded version of the
crisps that you see this is steak with
tartery buckwheat these things are so
wafer thin they have like this amazing
crunch the Airy the light the very
slight bitterness of the buckwheat lends
itself very well to the steak fragrant
red stew
consisting of yam and Highland Bali
which is the main cereal planted on the
Specter we also have Taro and sweet
potato chips
this one is with black pepper and sea
salt
it's very thin yet it's not crispy it
feels almost a little bit soggy
refreshing lime
what are all the refreshing chips
pass sweet potato chips natural flavor
I know this probably frustrates some of
you at home but the majority of people
here in China open crisp packets like
this as opposed to horizontally like in
the west because it's easier to open
this way easier to share when you reach
in you don't get salt stuck to your hand
and it's also just less effort we don't
need to brew away our way into things
not gonna lie it's not so bad so we had
the regular sweet sweet potato chips now
we have sweet potato chips with added
brown sugar
oh
why no oh
I'm not gonna waste as little time as
possible on these big chips they just
for people who want their chips to be
more brittle and less flavored
I don't know they suck the original or
barbecue here's original I mean this is
the third time we've done this don't
bother just trust me don't bother listen
they're all destroyed in there just they
don't have no taste they're flimsy
the baked are bad there's the better for
you and simply brand uh the better for
you is a lightly salted lightly salted
barbecue wavy lightly salted all these
right here I get it sodium can be an
issue for snack and chips a lot so why
not go with the lightly salted uh maybe
I mean 50 50 less sodium that's pretty
good right I mean a lot of these I'm
curious
have this compared to it
there's a 50 less this is a hundred
percent less I don't taste anything also
the simply
I guess the whole deal is they just use
simpler ingredients
made with three simple ingredients
potatoes sunflower oil and sea salt
there's also the simply barbecue thick
cut
I mean how much better could it be we
also have two exclusives from the simply
lineup which have 50 less saturated fat
the refreshing lime and the seaweed
guess what we even have lays french
fries let's go with the
original flavor these come in really big
packets by the way
[Applause]
is so incredibly salty I am so glad that
the owners only gave us this tiny packet
because I'm gonna just no I don't want
the rest oh cheese and butter french
fries pink grapefruit flavor I mean you
can't
see this and not try it
[Applause]
this is really good
this is so weird but it's really good
hot pink grapefruit Lays
I'm gonna pick that up and eat it
that's that good
culture
we also have seaweed flavor french fries
and
tomato flavor french fries but I am
dying to try this
Apple potato french fries
oh
I don't even know what that tastes like
no
no now we have one more
non-potato chip Lays
the air fried chicken breast
I have absolutely no idea how much
chicken is in here it looks like very
tiny pizzas or little crackers
it leaves me very confused
I do taste the chicken
but hey this is an interesting flavor
ah
Stacks stacks
stacks
have you seen any other lays food Wars
we've done I hate these for every reason
they are Pringle shaped chips in plastic
tubes instead of plastic bags first of
all
worse container right
does that sound like uh some chips are
intact
these chips are really messed up man not
a pleasant experience at all but I'm
contractually obligated to tell you
besides these two flavors you can also
get Stacks in Mesquite barbecue cheddar
salt and vinegar bacon and cheddar
potato skins buffalo wings with ranch
extra Flamin Hot flamas and chili lemon
please don't get them trust me they suck
we've got Stacks too and in many more
flavors as you can tell Stacks is
basically Lay's take on the Pringles but
whereas Pringles took 10 years to come
up with their saddle-shaped chip which
is actually known as a double curved
hyperbolic paraboloid
Stacks went with a single curved
hyperbolic cylinder so you can actually
see the difference
in the shape of the chip right here the
stacks by the way comes with a
fancy schmancy plastic tray that's meant
to keep it from breaking but hasn't
worked very well in this case here is an
intact stacks and here is an intact
Pringle to be honest they kind of look
similar the Pringle has an extra curve
down here whereas the stacks down here
appears to be a bit more flat now the
stacks also comes in tomato flavor
cucumber flavor there are some flavors
that I would love to try such as the
sizzled barbecue flavor
oh wow this is a good plastic tray
official right
black pepper
rib eye steak this I am actually very
excited to try finger licking red
braised poor there's maybe a hint of
pork in there
and some sugar and some caramelizing but
that's pretty much it
okay we've got one for you Stax fans out
there these are the stacks premium the
stacks black
the Chinese name actually says potato
workshop and apparently
it has real food ingredients so this is
avocado with mustard
why okay now we have purple potato so
basically sweet potato with
coconut milk
maybe it's an acquired taste oh
I mean you guys know I don't like
truffle now anyway I'm pretty low brow
but this is black truffle and black
pepper flavored potato chip Spanish ham
flavored potato chips I love me some
inberco jamon
I am praying that this is going to be
tasty
fire them all the rubbish
this is spicy crawfish
hmm oh yes
okay finally we have a winner from the
stacks premium lineup this is great and
I would say that this
tastes even more authentic than the
regular potato chip version of The Spicy
crayfish that we had earlier oh
roast chicken skewer wagyu beef
sour and sweet rose petals
oh come on ladies you're just playing
with me now this is delicious
wow
imagine
sitting in a nice warm milky bath
floating with rose petals and eating
this sweet and sour rose petal lace
that would be the best evening ever wow
this is great fantastic
we have a seaweed flavor I like my
seaweed we've had too much seaweed today
I'm pretty sure this is going to be okay
we also got purple balls these are so
stupid what is this we don't need a new
shape tell everyone in the biz we don't
need new shapes so I don't know what
this thing's supposed to be but you can
get it in sea salt honey barbecue
see some vinegar
white cheddar look at this it's all
hollow inside and
well
oh
it's like a giant checks
what what are we what are we doing here
Waze what are we doing here why what
what what what
now I know lays seems like going hard on
you guys but I have to say end in with
the dips lace dips are fantastic they
have three to choose from
the smooth Ranch the French onion and
the creamy jalapeno couldn't get it this
French onion dip
drugs any chip works with it let's do my
favorite Kettle jalapeno
Stellar this dip works on literally
everything
I would put this in my coffee if I could
it is so great
fantastic the dips are great check them
out
a 75 gram bag of American classic glaze
in China is 7.3 Yen or
1.06 our closest size to the 75 gram bag
is the 74.4 gram bag so 0.6 grams less
and it's 2.48 or
17.04 U.N that is a 134 cost increase in
the US right but then if you take into
account purchasing power parity then
lays charges the highest price in the
world for its chips here in China
so here in China even though the chip
Market only accounts for 15 of the snack
industry lays accounts for 50 of that
chip Market these guys are definitely
the creme de La Creme when it comes to
potato chips here in China and they've
got such a wide variety of flavors that
you will see them always in a prime
shelf location in every convenience
store across the country lays in the US
lasers like the chip right there's other
chip brands for lays probably the most
ubiquitous you see them everywhere they
have so many different options and
styles I think any type of potato chip
there's even remotely popular lasers and
knockoff version of it always good
always available
always decently priced I guess I think
lays has been incredible in adapting to
the Chinese market they've basically
gone and found all of the popular
flavors and combinations in China
whether it's street food or restaurant
food and put them into a convenient and
portable chip packet laser is incredible
at adapting because as you saw before
every like style they have besides a
regular potato chip is a style that
another chip brand hand that they just
took on the kettle chips that they taste
just like Miss Vicki's they got the wavy
ones which was Ruffles right
um the poppables which I don't know
bugles checks you tell me any
three-dimensional chip the stacks which
is going after Pringles I mean they
they're bloodthirsty this company they
will go after anyone
our classic lace aka the American flavor
are made of potatoes oil American
classic original seasoning which is
comprised of edible salt monosodium
glutamate five flavor nucleotide
disodium and silicon dioxide
our classic lays are made up of potatoes
vegetable oil which is canola corn
soybean and or sunflower oil and salt
now there are two ingredients we wanted
to highlight which are monosodium
glutamate AKA MSG and five flavor
nucleotide disodium these two
ingredients are used to give our chips a
Savory Umami flavor ah MSG hits the uh
black sheep of condiments now for those
of you who don't know what MSG is it's
used to add savoriness to food and was
also associated with something called
Chinese restaurant syndrome which has
since been debunked many times turns out
it was a hoax but basically the gist is
when you go to a Chinese restaurant
after eating its food you'll feel
headaches dizziness sore throat loss of
appetite you know MSG is not a culprit
it's naturally occurring in tomatoes and
Bone broths it's found in fermented
foods from cheese to Worcestershire
sauce to soy sauce awesome actually the
vast majority of MSG in the world is
made through fermentation just like
yogurt or vinegar MSG was a cause for
health concerns in the U.S for decades
and concerns still lingers today even
though the FDA considers the addition of
MSG to Foods as being generally
recognized as safe Gras both countries
use the food coloring caramel color in
our barbecued chips now certain types of
caramel color contain a byproduct called
4mei for methyl lumidazole
and studies found that it caused cancer
in rats and mice which led to campaigns
calling for it to be banned from foods
but it's also worth noting that this
byproduct is found when you roast foods
like coffee and meat in the FDA was like
eh it's fine
humans don't come close to the levels of
exposure that cause the rat tumors that
didn't stop the state of California
adding it to its Proposition 65 list of
chemicals quote known to the state of
California to cause cancer or
reproductive toxicity End quotes
a 30 gram packet of China lays American
classic flavor chips contains
162 calories
1.7 grams of protein 10.5 grams of fat
of which 5.3 grams are saturated fats
15.1 grams of carbs of which 0.4 grams
are sugars 0.8 grams of fiber and 170
milligrams of sodium a 28 gram bag of
classic glaze in the U.S contains 160
calories total fat 10 grams of which
saturated 1.5 grams carbs 15 grams and
170 milligrams of sodium we did find
that the 160 calorie chips with the
highest fat content are the cheddar and
sour cream chips here's what's in a bag
of those 160 calories 10 grams of fat of
which 1.5 are saturated 15 grams of
carbs and 170 ml kilograms of sodium
we have a very shocking Discovery
apparently lays healthiest chips are in
fact their least healthy in that they
have more calories on average than any
other lace product here in China and the
worst offender
[Applause]
oh is my hair growth serum the black
sesame and chia seed yam crisp now 100
grams of this will equal
598.7 calories or
168 calories for a 28 gram packet now in
a 30 gram portion you'll have
179.6 calories 1.6 grams of protein
13.3 grams of fat of which 6.6 are
saturated fat
13.7 grams of carbs and
212 milligrams of sodium which means
that the healthy yam chips are on
average 11 more calorific than any other
Lays chips containing less protein and
carbs and more sodium and fat
you know I always thought healthy just
meant not tasty but in Lay's case
apparently it also means less healthy
what a plot twist
okay I don't know is this guy any good
it says messy on his shirt oh is it
messy no it's not
that's not what it's Lionel Messi right
no that's not what he looks like that's
not him